all right we're here we're back as we do
we got a guest Furqan is here in the
house how's it going guys what's up so
background who's for a confer con is my
co-founder CTO at Bebo before we sold
and we've been working together I don't
know five six years now maybe six seven
years getting towards seven I think it's
one of those things where you just keep
saying five years and you know no matter
how long it's been but he has an
interesting background before that very
good background you want to give us like
the give the highlights the highlights I
grew up here in the Bay Area I got
started just programming as a kid and so
I had a unique experience where I worked
at a.com when I was fifteen and that was
kind of like well you're going to high
school at the time or did you drop out I
was going to high school I had just
finished my sophomore year and I was
really into computers and my dad was
like hey I know this guy they need to
hire some people they're looking to make
like a website at the time they had a
router for hotel rooms so it was like
hotels wanted to put in DSL and kind of
like good internet they're like oh you
got a we needed this interface like the
Linksys interface for your router now
just the HTML side of things yeah an
HTML at the time was really nothing it
was like you could put some stuff and I
showed my dad how to make a menu and he
was like wow this is a groundbreaker
there's no JavaScript how much were you
gettin pay that 15 to do this uh if I
had worked the whole year would have
been about 120 km boom comm boom
probably because they're hiring 15 year
olds but right and then that happens
then you did an e-commerce thing yeah
and so that company didn't work out
obviously spending money paying fifteen
year old hunter 20k exactly and so I
kind of was back at high school and then
I'm bored and I'm really into computers
and gaming and you know I had this idea
that like hey people like to kind of
trick out their cars like they like to
put lights and you know fun things in
their car like why don't people do this
with the computers people are really
passionate about it and so I looked it
up and I found some forums online and
people were doing this it's just there
was nowhere to buy things there's
nowhere to do things especially here in
the US so I started a ecommerce store
kind of accidentally I was like oh like
these things are really expensive if I
buy them in bulk I just get them cheaper
also awesome I'll have some more cash on
the side and I think we started eight
hundred bucks of stuff in the corner
garage and then within the first year we
did a million dollars of Revenue Wow
and it was like how old were you Oh 17
so Lee Shin high school at the time and
so that was pretty crazy because it went
from you know one corner of the garage
to full three-car garage to living room
family room like there's boxes
everywhere my parents were super
supportive of this obviously and so that
was kind of the early days I would say
and then we'll fast forward because
there's a lot more of the story but
we'll do the highlights so if I'm listen
to this you know whenever I ask people
over their background really what I'm
trying to say is you people a sense of
who you are and also it's kind of just
like credibility said why should you be
interesting what I'm you're trying to
make you're trying to impress people
yeah it's like this is the time to
basically brag so I'll brag for you
because you're a pretty humble guy you
don't brag a lot so the other
interesting parts are took a couple
years off played poker professionally
kind of in Europe traveling around that
was fun when you came back did your own
startup failed but then the next startup
which you started with Adam and a couple
other guys you guys tried and failed on
a bunch of IT guys I think it probably
nine ideas yeah it was about nine ideas
across two or three years that we tried
kind of you know one idea would see it
was real serious we tried that for about
nine months so then you're going through
like three months chunks of like really
bad right ideas and attempts and then
and my favorite anecdote of this whole
time because I think this is very very
you don't hear people talk about this
was sometimes when you guys were in
between ideas or you just were it wasn't
working what did you do you'd come to
the office knew what I mean literally
that's what you guys did at Monkey
inferno we were due for like an hour
these guys were just like that was the
day did you think that was weird like
Adam and those guys had had success I've
part of you was probably like look if if
these successful guys think this is all
right this can't be too bad but like I
would be anxious if we were doing that
um there was some anxiety but they were
super calm and collected so that well
why am I worried well so Adam was a
pretty wealthy yeah he previously worked
on a couple of ad tech companies and
they had grown to be pretty big I would
say like no one was worth maybe 50
million and you know the one before that
might have been in that range too and so
he had done some stuff John who is the
other co-founder there had worked at
like VMware
and he had worked at at products like
that Goblin and they were self funding
the company yeah they were self funding
and so I cannot believe how I would be
like no we're getting to work don't like
my buddy the cool thing was you sat
around you talked about things you how
many people we were probably like five
or six people got it so it was pretty
small
it wasn't I mean we had a good office in
pole to a bigger than we needed but you
could tell they're not worried I
shouldn't be worried you sit around for
a week you get some ideas then you go
and work on him and it all felt pretty
natural at that and the outcome of this
was what yeah so you cracked the nut
finally yeah so we had you know they had
a previous background in ad tech we had
made this product called Apple oven that
was an app where you could see what apps
your friends were using so it was like a
social network where if you're playing
candy crush
oh it says hey Sam's playing candy crush
and you should play too but we're like
wow this is pretty interesting people
really convert with this this would just
be an ad product and then that kind of
drove it and said wait we should just
make a real network out of this and then
we sat down we built that for a couple
months and then it kind of skyrocketed
after that and how big how big is it now
they're really massive now it's been a
while since I've been over there but you
know a couple years back they had big
liquidity event over one point four
billion so and I think they've probably
grown in multiple since then yeah I mean
I heard that it sold like only three
years effort started yeah it was really
fast and it was doing like six or seven
hundred million in revenue like some
crazy number yeah it was magical to see
what product market fit really looks
like like I always thought oh these
things are working no they weren't
working and this was what working looked
like and it was probably one of the best
versions of it so maybe my views a
little skewed on that but the first
first month it was like man we just jump
up to like 10,000 plus and revenue a day
and then you just kind of keep
skyrocketing up from that and like it's
pretty crazy as an engineer too because
now your servers are being hammered
you're like running around all night
like pulling all-nighters just because
money's flowing and you got to kind of
keep it up and so that was kind of crazy
but fun so the the app 11 story is four
million bucks and self-funding initially
then they raised a small strategic round
i don't know exactly what the totals but
about five million bucks total funding
right yeah I think that's exactly what
it was and then
the first liquidity events they sold a
portion of the company to a Chinese
company for over 1.4 billion and so
that's like massive capital efficiency
you were you know CTO kind of co-founder
there so we met after that we started
working together became you know you
know really good friends and have built
a bunch of stuff together and what I
like about you which is why I wanted you
to on the podcast is not necessarily
we're not gonna talk too much about
Apple of and that's just establish who
you are you are like me you're an idea
guy you always have a bunch of ideas you
see interesting stuff but you're deeply
technical but then get the business side
and the product side too and there's
very few people who do I'm definitely
gonna ask about app loving and a little
bit okay before we even get to the ideas
let me I gotta tell you something real
quick cuz this is related so my best
friend started fungal which was a
plug-ins competitor they raised sixteen
million dollars when they got acquired
they had 100 million in cash what is it
self worth 750 half of what you guys
sold for it very successful yesterday
Jack was this was after you left okay so
we have to apologize a little bit
yesterday Lance Armstrong popped in and
our episode got ruined kind of ruined or
or made or made whatever it was hectic
and we did this thing it was cool Sean
you left Jack was here it was me and
Lance and Adam and Jack just chillin
right here and Jack's kind of savant II
like he's like real smart but he doesn't
pay attention to a lot of things and we
were talking about the podcast and I was
saying Lance how BIG's your podcast he
said it's like whatever a hundred
thousand listeners he goes it took me a
long time to build that up you know
after I got cut out or cut off and Jack
was like what cut out what do you like
what happened like Apple shut you down
or something he goes no you don't like
from the incident that happened seven
years ago like I like everything dropped
off and he goes jack was like what what
do you mean and Lance later explained it
Lance looked at me it he goes he's like
is this guy serious I'm like yeah dude
he's like a business of Oz what happens
he doesn't know and he goes this is
awesome say if you got a hankering for
people like this Robbie he goes goes
jack
I basically went from hero to zero
overnight like I lost everything and
Jack was like oh okay Pro and I did
like rub you know like it was hilarious
that's amazing and if you jack did a
whole episode and you can kind of tell
he's like and the stuff he cares about
he's so deep in those like Rain Man and
then other stuff he's completely
oblivious too which is awesome
yeah it was it was so funny
and Jack started your guys's compare
maybe their first I don't know but
competitors so it reminded me of that so
what you want to do I want to hear some
ideas you said you have a story or is
that the story or you know I'll tell it
tomorrow okay cool so we want to have
guests that come in and bring their
ideas stuff they find interesting so
either little phenomenon they've
observed ideas they've been cooking up
something off their list I have on their
phone whatever it is so do you have
stuff like that you have a night a list
of ideas he does or no I wrote down some
ideas for this okay actually just keep
them up here and like you know the
important ones make their way out let's
talk about the process where do you get
a lot of like weird window ideas come to
you usually when I'm not trying to come
up with the night like in the shower
shower driving just kind of around not
really thinking about anything and then
something pops up the second one I would
say is like when I'm reading online like
if you read something interesting you're
like wait that's cool but it would be
cooler if it was and then like that's
kind of where my mind wanders I think
that the best idea is you just steal all
right yeah so like it's kind of like
that you're like oh but what if you
applied it like the way this restaurant
industry is this restaurants working
they should actually apply that to like
Indian food and it would be way bigger
right yeah it's like re mixing right
it's like I want to sample some ideas
real quick and then I want to turn it
into my own right so what you got what's
interesting to you okay so I'll start
with one that we went go-karting a
couple weeks back and so I'm really into
kind of VR AR I mean you know this I've
kind of gives you an oculus just yeah
you can you know feel my you gave him
one great gift right that's awesome
yeah I was like John you gotta do this
you're never gonna buy one on your own
you're gonna be a skeptic forever here
you go are you using it yeah because he
was telling me he's like there's just
one thing you're cuz I was skeptical I
was like is there any good games like
what am I gonna do with this he's like
dude you gotta try this PokerStars thing
and I was like oh yeah what a VR Poker
why do I need that it is [__] amazing
have you tried this thing we see what
I've done boxing I played all the games
but I didn't got it for the poker one
it's incredible
I'm gonna go buy an oculus with supply
yeah seriously you should there are sold
out so it's gonna be tough but you know
maybe we can get you one too you really
can't buy one right now they're totally
from from Christmas they just completely
sold out and then they haven't been able
to refill it they said it was January
than February now it's March and then
they're talking about all these delays
from China that's a good sign for VR
yeah I mean they totally it's the first
device where I looked at it and I said I
can give it to somebody that's not a VR
junkie and they would actually get
excited about it and I think the pokken
one is great because you actually people
want to build these really immersed
experiences like boxing but actually you
don't really want entertainment like
that all the time I actually want more
sit on the couch experience yeah so you
know some of the things I've been
thinking about it if you are saying what
can I build while I'm on the couch yeah
we wouldn't go karting and you know when
you go go-karting it's really about how
quickly do you make these turns how fast
are you how good of a driver are you
you know how aggressive are you you know
things like that and afterwards we were
just kind of talking about some ideas
and I was like dude it would be cool if
we could you know go to a go karting
place but it's like Mario Kart instead
where you have these AR goggles over
your head and it's not about quick turns
and it's like the longer track where you
can kind of like have some space but I
you know would digitally go over this
box and I now have a weapon that I could
shoot at your car and if I hit you
successfully your car kind of shuts down
for a second and you're stuck so I think
the real-life Mario Kart is this like
the sandbox thing so this would be like
sandbox or like Museum of ice-cream it'd
be a place you go put on this thing play
with a bunch of frogs big on your
sandbox like laser tag it's like you
better be laser exactly do you think
that sandbox is a big business I think
sandbox is fantastic I mean it's hard to
see if there's going to be successful or
not because retail has all these
problems and having space has all these
problems but if I retail well yes not
retail but they're they kind of have
retail spaces right like they want to be
fricking Mordor right yeah they want to
be like in a spot where there's a lot of
I mean it's just an activity it's just
like escape room or something it's like
escape room but it escape Herman I know
I know guys who owned like 200 escape
rooms are they awesome it's an amazing
business because escape rooms are super
lightweight you don't do anything you
have a
if one person you buy the kit and you
just keep like reassembling the room and
you have these like very small for the
big as that company well it's not one
company but it's it's like like you can
just own a different price yeah but you
can own a McDonald's franchise they
still report revenues as one yeah
primary I've never been in I would I
will never go to an escape room that's
my fear I don't want to guess I'm really
cost of phobic I don't like lying I know
I will never go in general VR or a our
experiences are gonna be I think
fantastic and you could see theme parks
going to this like I heard about a theme
park that has a roller coaster ride in
VR where they give you goggles you're in
this kind of mechanical thing but then
you're actually in a dungeon and there's
lava and like it's a totally immersed
experience and I think that people are
going to experience it first like that
and I could totally see you coming up
with all kinds of different content
types and whether it's Mario Cart or
escape room that's a great point so
here's a cool model of this I have a
buddy who worked at this company called
two bit circus Weaver heard of them no
so the guy that got the founder his dad
started chuck-e-cheese is Nolan whatever
the guys name is Atari guy I started
Atari started chuck-e-cheese and his son
started the thing called two bit circus
and I love the concept
I think the son kind of I don't know the
guy but like my read on the situation is
just sort of like a TD he wants to do a
million things not really like executing
on this business as he should but the
concepts amazing they go city to city
traveling circus like Cirque de Soleil
or whatever and they pop up this thing
and it's like a weekend thing where
parents bring their kids and all the
attractions are like digital wonders so
it's like VR thing a big a hologram
thing and they were doing really well
every city they were going to they're
selling out like crazy but he was also
getting distracted they were doing
things like a company would be like hey
we'll give you half a million dollars to
do our company retreat yeah and then
boom the whole company Nick the CEO
comes in and says hey we had to go do
this corporate retreat and the company
is like dude we need like one direction
but can you Henry can you look up dave
and buster's revenue and look up
chuck-e-cheeses I bet chuck-e-cheeses
owned by private equity makes a killing
and if you've gone to a checking there's
way down well where I'm from Missouri
they were probably popular it's like
we're like like trashy poor people go I
mean it's pretty cool it's pretty wack
like like I wouldn't go there because it
was famous for like the parents would
fight it was like Pee Wee hockey and
chuck-e-cheese that's like where parents
get drunk and fight what's the number by
the way does it pick up Henry when he
says no they repeat it yeah repeat what
he said
Dave Buster's three million Chuckie
Cheese almost a billion dollars annual
revenue but definitely ripe for like
doing something new because these things
are stale
it's Chuckie Cheese public it just say
it's a public company if like my stock
well I want to see what the income is no
I'm into this I think that these things
are cool I think I'm terribly into it
when I tried oculus I was like I'm gonna
quit my company and only do this by the
way random story i I found this YouTube
channel once that was talking about all
these old brands that are just gone to
[__] like a Chucky Cheese and here's
like hey this guy just short stocks and
he was like my short pic of the year is
tootsie roll and he was like you ever
met anyone likes tootsie roll I love him
he's like people like tootsie roll all
35 and up he's like no kid wants to 0
they go out for Halloween go public they
get tootsie roll they throw that [__]
away he goes Tootsie Roll has no other
products it's just tootsie roll and
their population is dying you know
secondly the owner is like some 76 year
old woman who will never sell the
company so nobody can turn it around
nobody can change it that company's just
going to troll surprise it's another
company and so it was like a short the
stock so I watch this two-minute YouTube
video and I was like I took out a short
[Laughter]
so another thing that I would do I love
this I would also look Six Flags has had
a hell of a turnaround positive so the
guy who there's this guy named Bob
Pitman and he was one of the
inspirations for me starting the hustle
because Bob Pitman was he created MTV
when he was in his 20s and then he went
started the thing called this thing
called the pilot group which launched a
loads of different email newsletters
including Thrillist which is like a huge
thing it's like a billion-dollar media
thing anyway Bob Pittman was is now the
CEO of I heart media and formerly was
also the CEO of Six Flags and he turned
it around and it there it does it's
really good it's been around forever you
know and it abscent flows but it's good
yeah I think entertainment can always
level up and when you're leaving the
house to go do something the more
immersed and more exciting it is it like
that's what you want like I can get all
the rest of the stuff at home but like
that's why I think said what satin box
is fantastic
the only negatives I've heard is hey
I've gone to it twice it was similar
content but they're gonna rub that out
they're gonna keep growing it I think
it's gonna be amazing I love this
spin-off of this idea for the lazy
people that I have okay you got to go to
this place and go go Carleigh alright
what's the other why can I stay at home
correct so if you replace the carts with
drones and you let people sit at home on
a controller and control these drugs
real life drive drones are flying around
this warehouse and I'm fighting you and
again same thing is all digital so I can
hit something shoot you your drone just
like flies and brakes you got to go
let's start over again hit of people who
just go pick up ok alright I have I can
add to this there's this guy I know I
don't know if they're public so I won't
I won't talk about him yet but anyway
he's got what he what they did was in
Vegas or in Nevada where it's really
cheap they bought something like a
hundred or a thousand a significant
amount of claw machines you know claw
machines like for arcade machine yeah
and you download the app and you pay a
certain amount of money and you can you
control the claw machine remotely test
and it picks up the item and drops it
down to the thing and then you just get
huge in Japan
you just get emailed like I don't know
if they I don't know what the mailing
system is I don't know if you actually
get mail bad thing or if it's a gift
card that you get sent but I saw my
friend doing this on his phone I was
like what are you playing what game is
that he goes oh there's a arcade in
Japan and I'm controlling the claw so
okay but here's how my buddy's building
this business he's building it to be
like like H he's building it to where
it's gonna take off and they're gonna
after all the value and it's just gonna
slowly die I guess you've known fad
basically is what you're saying like he
knows it's a fad yeah which I love I
like that those things but that's how
he's building it do it on like wish
product because they're so cheap that
you could kind of like have some
conscription thing where it's like hey
you have to get one random which product
but yeah that's a wish to do your
browsing wish and after two minutes it's
like enter bonus round
you have the claw in our supply
warehouse pick something up I'm into
this I think it's cool
alright what else you got okay wait hold
on here's what we'll do actually in the
next couple days I'll come prepared with
some Six Flags and chuck-e-cheese
numbers okay I'm interested in this I
want to know what the start-up costs are
of for sandbox VR and I was tweet at us
if you like cuz we nerd out on like I
wonder how that business does and we go
look up the numbers and figure out who
this guy is who's Bob Pitt man and how
much income do they make I don't know if
we're unique in that but if you like
that stuff like either in the Facebook
group just my first million or on
Twitter tell us if that's like just be
like more of that or less of that just
be honest yeah cuz that's the weird
thing with podcast you don't know what
they want
yeah what else so in general like I look
at theme so it's like okay Apple
releases a bunch of random devices so
I'll call them ear pods not really
random but this Apple pencil yeah it's a
hundred twenty-five bucks it's expensive
and like the iPad pro is expensive but
then I'm like great this new capability
is there what product exists for it and
so you know recently I've been kind of
playing around a lot with the iPad and
I'll kind of try to show you guys I can
hold the my card do you use a are you
one of the like computer you get rid of
computer only use ipad i'm i think
that's weird
i think it's [__] weird it's i I like
this in certain cases like what I'm
traveling it's a lot better than me
lugging around my laptop did work pay
for that no this is mine so I just
forgot I like to submit expenses
reimbursement really bad was like like
when we sold people how many
unreimbursed things how much dollar
amount did you have is like the tens of
thousands yeah yeah we did
digit range I should be better at that
but you know Adam did that I had to pay
him five granite-like submit [__] life
has been good to me so I'm not really
not stressing anything yeah so the
general theme is like new hardware comes
out what can I do with this yeah that's
the general diamond so one of the things
I've been playing with is this app
called flow and it's basically like this
kind of whiteboard app right and so it's
kind of hard to show obviously but the
idea for me was you know you sit in a
meeting room right and you you love the
whiteboard you love getting up and movie
yeah he does that [__] I like to get my
Steve Jobs on well he always has like
analogies over [__] he's like we're try
to pull the racecar but let's start with
the bicycle the idea was okay you take
this kind of experience with the iPad
and pencil but this whiteboard over here
should just be digital right so if I
want to show you something I just turned
on here and it just shows up there
you're like no no and you want to kind
of feed off of it and like I said so for
those who can't see what you're saying
so you're spacing you got a little iPad
in front of you a little tablet you're
in a big meeting room if you you should
be able to quickly sketch something or
write something or draw something and it
just used the whiteboard as a display
like it's a TV correct and then it's
remote friendly so everybody can get the
same whiteboard experience cuz I mean
what happens if your remote that
happened to me yesterday I was remote
conference again the guy gets up he's
like here's what what here's what this
really means he drew something on
whiteboard I can't see and everyone in
the meeting was like oh yeah that makes
total sense
I'm just the video ask you a bunch of
people so do you know this guy named
Wayne I forget his last name he sold
something to Twitter yeah they're doing
digits now mah mAh I think it's more
anyway I was talking to him he said
they're 100% remote and Isaac how do you
do that cuz we're struggling with this
whole whiteboard thing and he was like
man there's this one app and they never
update and that's kind of what we've
hacked together to use this is a problem
that yeah I think people are going to
remote work both because there's really
good talent elsewhere that you're like
man this is a perfect fit but you're not
here and that's not a good enough reason
anymore and then the second thing is
just caustic if you're in the city like
people they kind of don't like you know
they don't want to pay that much for
their house so just basically making the
whiteboard work for remote workers yeah
or even if you're here yeah yeah like I
still want a big view of it if I'm here
like if we're all here we want to get
that that's badass I'm into it
so the pencil and the iPad I think is a
good combination to where people will
have that around I think it'll become
more common now you can kind of connect
all these together so last podcast I was
saying meeting tech that makes meetings
more effective and efficient because all
like so many billions of dollars are
spent in people's time in meetings do
you know how cheap I mean your it would
cost way less anything to make this you
know that okay this is a screen this is
a 55 inch I think out there we have a 65
inch TCL 4k or no waiting at the 4k
1080p you know how much that cost it's
like no no it was like 250 or 180 it's
like probably cheaper than this why
that's the retail yeah like on Amazon I
bought it for I think for sure less than
300 maybe less than 200 yeah I believe
that screenings are really cheap and so
where else can you put screens and I
think you can actually enhance the
meetings if somebody puts up slides I
want to write over the slides that guy I
think you unlock more capabilities than
just supplement what you have today and
I think that that's where this will
become superior than us going to the
whiteboard with you know those expo pens
and kind of writing there right so
meeting tech yeah I think we had it
yesterday I mean I was but now you're
getting it you you didn't have you I
didn't have a good exam set a meeting in
a box yeah I was trying to get to that
but then I stumbled the initial thing I
said meeting in a box and it sounded
stupid to me my shark showed up like a
chump in a box
nobody wanted to walk around with the
Bluetooth headset right we think we all
agree you didn't look cool you look
attacking look it was a known douchebag
thing yeah yeah it was like having the
cellphone on your belt yeah perfect and
so I was like great people have a pause
now and so what else can you build with
this again apples unlocking capabilities
and hardware so what software can you
build and so there's two ideas ones
minds one
else's but I'll take it as my craft yeah
exactly whoever says it it's theirs yeah
by the way Apple or air pods what how
much 10 million units X amount of time
so what's that 10 bit is that 10 billion
in sales
yeah just multiplied by let's say 100
yeah yeah it would be a fortune 500
company yeah I agree it's fantastic and
so one of the things I was thinking
about it was great if I have these on
all day can I just have this on cannot
connect it to like my wife or like
somebody right and so whether you do it
for work or for a personal you always
have it on there's no audio flowing but
then if I'm like hey Sean what's up it
knows do you have your ear pods on if it
doesn't it tells me hey he's not there
but you can record a message you'll get
it later right but if you're there
you'll just hear my audio and you still
aren't on yet you're kind of opting
again to be like yo what's up man like
it's like how do you take the phone call
away from like that and you're like I'm
not gonna give this capability to
everybody there's couple close people in
my life like my wife did I'm gonna be
like great I just want to have this on
and this capability that's there and so
it's like in the office they do this in
the TV show oh yeah Jim and Pam Hammond
yeah this is good cuz it's not it's not
on when you don't want it on so let's
say I have my earbuds in
you have yours in and I'm walking around
I'm at lunch I have this idea for the
podcast I basically just say yo Sam what
we should do is we should do this and
then you basically receive but you're
not sending back unless you say whatever
the keyword like though you know how
Alexa works right like it's like Shawn
or whatever and that's way more
lightweight than me picking up my phone
and starting at the type or phone call
like who wants to do that right so phone
calls feel weird 100% right now yeah I
I'm I'm less bullish on that in the
first two okay okay the second version
of this idea with ear pods was you know
for us all right
oh you're homie yeah one of our friends
and we're doing small hackathon at the
house and he's like coming up with this
idea again for everybody wait wait
you're doing a hackathon at your home
like for fun yeah just for fun
damn Eddie you do this like every week
right weeks like so what do you guys do
Jake's here Jake you did you go to the
last one yeah we just kind of sit around
a table we're on
tough we're talking about ideas we come
up with something and we just kind of
try to make it usually you don't end up
finishing on the first one but then just
second when you try again the third one
you try had any kind of [__] nerds
what you build what you build it the
last one you me talk about it yeah so
Jake Jake was making this thing where he
was like it'd be cool if you could test
your website from like locations around
the world but it would like video record
what it looked like and how it loaded so
not only do you get this like technical
got a number yeah and then you show
people this is how crappy our website
looks like from some random country or
in the US and write what it looks like
for other people and so that's awesome
yeah that's really awesome everyone's
kind of testing numbers but we're visual
yeah what you care about is oh look how
long that took to load look how shitty
this look have you heard of user test is
it user voice review their test testing
you know user testing yeah I'm that's
like a hundred fifty million dollar a
year business a lot - my mom works at
user testing really if it's that it's
huge right big it's it's they're trying
to go public and you know so that means
they're at that scale where they're
doing 100 hundred million plus yeah and
all they do is there's someone in the
Midwest who's cheap who recorders all
right well let me look at your website
okay I'm scrolling down I don't really
know what that's been about laying
confusion this is more about performance
no but they but they but they there's
both they're similar
there are similar issues yeah and I
think you know today he's looking at it
like a performance tool like how do you
kind of make it load well but I think
you could totally look at it and apply
some machine learning to it where it's
like this doesn't seem to work well it's
below the fold on these devices right
like some of those things when you
design it and you like put it together
you're not thinking oh what does it look
like on the iPad right and then you kind
of just show it like that and then you
have a video but also it could detect
and say man this is like your main
button that is going up down here and
you know you could are you gonna do it
the job Jake I like that project the
okay so I already said this what was the
other project so this idea was around
cooking and you're like in the kitchen
and you're like oh I want to like hear
these recipes and things like that and
so again your hands are dirty in the
kitchen yeah what do you do you pull out
your phone your laptop doesn't make
sense right like and so the idea was you
have your air pods on it kind of walks
you through the steps and you can go
next go back and it's like you know a
little recipe the name that you came up
with for it but I think you could come
up with a better name for
kitchen in a box I think you call that
kitchen pods or something and I was like
God that isn't right this house have you
uh okay so aunt this guy named Andrew
Mason you know you know that name Terri
Groupon he a few years ago his second
act he started this thing detour detour
there it is
they shut it down and he pivoted to D
script the script a podcast thing and
anyway
detour it was awesome
it was so cool this was before air pods
so did you do well oh I used to do them
all the time but I understand how it
wouldn't be huge but I was a power-tool
product not a great business yeah and so
what it was is you know how when you go
to a museum and you have a guided tour
that sounds like alright when you get to
this point press this thing and there
and then you press the button you tell
you about it you see this painting you
see there's a small little smudge that
you'll see up laughter that what
happened he got angry he did whatever so
what they do this but they do it for
cities so it's guided walking tours
interesting but you know you know this
American life like you know how it's
like really highly produced podcasts
where you can like hear noises and they
did that but it was GP it was work at
your GPS and what they would do is they
would say alright walk past the street
past Bush Street keep walking and then
it would play music and then it would
tell when you got there and it would say
now look down to your right you see that
hole that was there that actually came
here from this time and it's it's
awesome it's so cool shut it down
anyway what you're describing is almost
like the cooking version of that
activity version which would be
significantly larger than the detour
version cuz the detour because you cook
all the time the detour version I would
do it unlike a my wife is out of town it
does suck to have your hands covered in
food and then be like oh let me go to my
iPad or my phone and like try to like
scroll and click and zoom and like
figure out this recipe how many
tablespoons was supposed to be has there
ever been a big business built of around
recipes other than an ad based media
company I'm not sure the problem with a
lot of these ideas you start thinking
too far ahead you're like I don't want
to go do this thing because what does it
turn into but I think generally the
concept if you took guided tours like
that concept and you said what else in
my life could be guided that's
interesting I think there's a couple of
very interesting businesses there all
right interesting
totally interesting products maybe
interesting businesses - totally
interesting probably there's a workout
version of this that's doing all right
which is like you go to the gym and it's
like in your ears and it's music app
telling you what to do I use it all the
time
active you know what that is it's
similar I use it on a [__] basis I pay
$100 a year for Ethan spoke at hustla
con tens of millions in subscription
revenue it's what you're describing but
for working out so I think if you have a
great product in a space where a lot of
people are doing it you can come up with
a business plan like 100 bucks a year
that matches some I agree with you so
people cook people go to the gym like
what else are they doing day to day like
I think guided meditation is another one
bit oh yeah really there's the model
right and so there's probably five
others in that space but I think earpods
made it different than Bluetooth
headsets and headphones you know like so
here's here's a lot guys everyone yeah
that's why he gets the seat forgot it
for meditation a lot of people don't
like to sit and meditate like that just
doesn't do it for them their mind races
all this stuff and like the answer right
now is like no that's the point do it
and like sure that's that might be true
but for a lot of people what it means is
like [__] this I'm gonna do something
else and so there's all these other
types of meditation like transcendental
or whatever where you're chanting it's
like a little more active and and
there's all kinds of meditation hiking
is meditation exercises meditation
because you're controlling your
breathing in a certain way you're
clearing your mind space and you you
know you're freeing your mind and so I'm
curious if somebody can do this sort of
detour version that's about walking and
you know it's basically God in
meditation but it's active not sit down
on a pillow and do nothing for thirty
minutes or whatever it is yeah like when
I would do those detours you did him
right I never did want to well we did
well I did one where I went to the
Castro and it was all about the AIDS
epidemic and you got to know Harvey snow
or snow
what's Harvey Harvey Milk you know the
gay activist that was like killed
whatever he was a gay activist that was
murdered and it was during the 80s when
the whole aids thing was going on and
the guy talking he was like now this is
the last time that I hugged Harvey
before he died and and then he's like
now this house up here like these guys
lived here and on top these guys live
here they
all died and I was like so emotionally
right okay that gets me thinking you
know I think this would be not I don't
think this would work but like you know
yesterday you and Lance Armstrong were
both like the podcast I like best are
these true-crime ones what if you did a
true-crime version of the detour thing
where it's murder mystery kind of creeps
you the [__] out as you walk around
that's cool real crimes from your city
yeah or you have to so we done trends we
did a report on this these app what are
those what are those calls again the you
know I'm talking about give here we all
know like these serialized video apps
that [__] the lady who started it she
sold her thing to song if I man I gotta
remember what it was anyway you you you
get it's like choose-your-own-adventure
okay for thriller not watching so
basically we did a report on it our
hypothesis was that actually the erotic
novels romance novels it's the biggest
segment you're talking about hooked
hooked yeah yeah hooked right anyway I
think it's a I I don't know if it's a
great business but it's a okay one they
scaled up revenue hooked was doing I
think 20 million plus in revenue for
yeah but I think return was stupidly
high yeah anyway what we're describing
is and when we did the report it was
romance novels and thrillers had the
highest here's the general print
principal though like cooked is the
modern-day goosebumps so when we were
growing up we would read Goosebumps
books and that was what hooked us as a
kid and you love to read and hooked said
well now every kid's got a phone what if
we delivered this through this kind of
SMS format but it sees like scary
stories goosebumps style and and what
you were talking about earlier with like
you know chuck-e-cheese modern day if
you're trying to brainstorm ideas this
is one format to think about what did I
love as a kid
what's the modern-day version of that
and because that's a great array more
people's desires tend to stay the same
yeah that's the tools of technology that
updates and opens up new opportunities a
good framework okay can I ask you about
Apple Evan yeah I got one more idea oh
go for it go for it
I'll kind of plug a company invested
into so I invested in this company
called lucid drone I think I told you
about it they have they basically
created a drone that can window wash big
buildings and so instead of sending like
a five person crew and ask
where did you find that there were a YC
company so you know YC produces still
fantastic companies I like these guys
because it was like we got this you know
it's not just drone tech and then guy
nowhere but it's like then it's awesome
application yeah specific application
and then you think about you're like
yeah five people hanging from a building
or one guy working the drone from the
bottom and washing it and all those
legal yeah and so they're they're out
there in a couple of cities I think
there's gonna be small regulations
they're gonna have to go but this makes
sense it's a lot safer and a lot better
when did they go come on saves you money
if you're the building owner safer than
having humans up there trying to wash
windows sad way to lose a life what a
bold idea great idea and what they did
is they actually stopped so they tried
to go to the building owners and they
were like oh man the building owners are
like well we have a service like you
know it's too complicated so they went
to the guys who were servicing the
building they're like hey I could make
your business more efficient so they're
sending five guys out per job you can do
five more jobs instead of renting this
crazy scaffold you just release our
drone and it's like you make their
business more valuable you're not taking
their business and then you don't have
to go do all the building to building
sales oh my god I love this one way of
looking at it was oh we're gonna put
those guys out of business
instead said no you're my customer
correct we make you more efficient
exactly and I think that's some of the
best tech I see is that it's not about
replacing the whole workflow it's like
how do we make these people more
efficient how do we allow them to have
more capabilities and then they can do
more they can do a better job and that's
kind of like I think what I look for in
the emerging tech lucid drones Lisa the
other genius thing about that is if you
wanted to do this you would either have
to go sell every building and and that's
a lot of sales or if you go to the
company like you said the company that
already does the window-washing they
might have already 50 clients so now one
sale gets you 50 man that's badass
we I'm big fans of boring things like
window-washing I think it would that
would be right my alley
and to add this thing to it would be
neat and never if you told me that
someone had that idea I'd be like no
it's it's really interesting into my
spin off the remix of their idea was
probably you guys I don't know if you
guys you have a car right yeah I'm sorry
great you guys both have car city but I
never wash my car I never go to a car
wash maybe there's no if I could just
have a little drone this it's in my
garage that can come up
wash my car for me every so often or if
you're in a place where it snows and how
do I pour some water in the windshield
so I don't gotta go do that and I can
get into the car like that's what that's
how ya like that you know this was like
a huge failure cherry but those humans
yeah this is a Roomba
yeah no I'm not washes your car totally
but I looked at like the background of
why I was like that's so stupid who on
earth think that was a good idea it's a
big thing in a lot of different
countries that and check this out
bringing gas drink a yeah bring gas to
you in foreign markets that's like the
way that gas works so car washes
I say well are funny I always have to
correct or tell people I say funny get
prepared car washing can you not say why
can't say it's a Midwestern thing wash
like it's easy are washing and giving
the disclaimer no I can't say I can't
say car why I know it's like El car
cleaning if somebody says like what's
your greatest weakness just make their
way into my words it's it's a bit lesser
thing a lot people say it anyway that's
interesting but I never would have
thought I'm I that's kind of cool but
how on earth could you build a machine
that does it I mean that's because the
drone need to be pretty smart to do that
or no no I think the thing I like about
this technology space right now is a lot
of the research work is done and so
people have made drones that can fly
that could follow you like there's
literally sky do yep I say a thousand
bucks do you go running in the woods
yesterday like demo video and it follows
you if you haven't seen this demo video
search sky do that [__] though it's
amazing literally go you like throw the
camera watch that one now the one failed
yeah these guys say they can do it how
about this go on YouTube and look up the
users who are doing this and they're
recreating it and you can see it works
okay and so like snowboarding and skiing
and stuff yes snowboarding is another
one I mean a GoPro was like one step up
but now if you got this drone that can
call there I love this [__] man drones
and VR just we need a drone filming this
that's just whoever's talking it just
turns to them and just does the cut just
picks up the right my
I had one of the first DGI ones and it
fell out of sky at a thousand feet
ruined it but a lot of this technology
there's been so much research work done
that's moved it forward and I think it's
at the spot now where it needs
application engineers and not that seem
you know you don't need to be a PhD with
computer science and all these math
degrees to go create this technology you
take the work that they've built and
they've kind of established and then
apply it to these things and so drunk
flying a drone is trivial enough
building the drone is trivial now and
then the software is easy to program a
drone to fly object recognition and
computer vision is easy now and so you
combine these two that's called easier
technologies now because of all the
research work that was done and then you
can kind of create this product from it
and so I've built these small drones or
like these little 4-inch drones they're
a you have yeah yeah I programmed my own
flight controller that one didn't work
as well I used the pre-programmed flight
controller that worked a lot better but
I get really excited about these
technologies when I without a college
degree without a you know deep technical
expertise can go and learn about it and
I really just used Google like that's my
source for everything how old are you
I'm 35 you're one of the more
interesting people I've ever met he's
cool interesting interesting to you
he just my interests align with yours
but he's more intelligent and more
technically savvy and he could actually
make the things that I think I wish I
could make yeah
can you talk about Apple Evan because
you said something so the other day I
was talking to someone about businesses
and I'm like when it's working do you
know what's working what's that feel
like and you made a comment earlier like
it's the first time I've ever seen we're
just this is what working feels like
right what what what what was that like
it's it's the feeling of like like when
you when you're you know slamming on
your brakes in the car and the car is
kind of doing its own thing and you're
like I'm not controlling the car it is
just flowing on its own it's like it's
that feeling where you know you're you
built all these products and even at
Apple oh and we did nine ideas before
that I've done this
for a long time where I'm just trying
idea after idea I try to get people to
use it and you're looking for these good
signals and you're trying to spot it and
then when it's really working
it's not about spotting it it's so
obvious that there's no question that
it's working and so it's all the charts
are flying up but then every day you're
not even like men is it working or is it
not
it's so obvious like I got to do XY and
Z - so you know these problems that are
coming up kind of day in and day out and
so it's definitely a feeling where the
pull from the market is so strong that
there's no there's no middle ground
it's I always thought it was like oh
it's I'm gonna kind of realize when I'm
close to it but it's actually very
binary it's like you're here and it's
not working and you're trying to push
into the market what you need to do but
when it happens it just kind of takes
off and you know I just I don't have
really good analogies for it yet except
for that like it just it's like the loss
of control the market is in control
almost and you're just like trying to
catch up and like you know get into that
mindset of like okay great this is
working we're gonna keep like pushing
whatever we need to do to kind of
support this case what was the revenue
growth I mean you guys were at zero then
was it like one month it could've been
like 20 grand the next month it was like
a million I mean was it that substantial
it wasn't that crazy but I think the
interesting thing that I learned was
there you know there were a lot of
players in the market where you'd go to
this weather app right and the weather
app would do like you know you never
realized the scale of some of these apps
you and at that time it's like man this
thing is doing 200 million
you know impressions per day and I'm
like a weather app like really like why
is it so big and then you're like great
if we get this customer these things can
happen and so I think the weather the
weather app does how many impressions I
think I forgot which weather app it was
whether it was a weather bug or the
weather app but it was like 200 million
impressions a day like and I was like I
was really surprised at some of the
scale of some of these apps and like you
know yes we had the best ad platform yes
we made no we made all these small
tweaks to the product to like make it
work better and we made our server scale
and we did all these things but I think
to me the fascinating thing was there
were all these major players you didn't
actually realize how big some of these
opportunities were and kind of working
at Apple of and I always like wait I
want to go
like when I left there it was like I'm
not like a huge fan of like ad products
like naturally it that's not the product
that I get excited about I love money so
I like great it's a fantastic business I
like that and I was like oh I'm gonna go
make these apps and games that are gonna
go do this and actually that's how I ran
into Sean I think he had checked out one
of my games after AngelList was that
right yeah I saw one AngelList and I was
like something doesn't add up either
this guy's full of [__] cuz who would
leave this company that's crushing it
like most people when you finally hit a
grand slam you want to do the victory
lap and people stay for seven years and
then they write this cheesy letter about
how great the journey has been and
they're finally ready for their next
chapter he basically left after three
years you weren't even fully vest in
right yeah left a little bit on the
table again I'm not complaining cuz
everything's been fantastic and but it
was something counterintuitive I was
like why would this guy leave either he
got kicked out he got fired he's not
good bubble blah I was like or this
guy's amazing he really just does love
me his story was like I just love
startups I want to build something that
consumers use not really an ad tech
platform and he was like I was
interested in mobile because I saw how
big these mobile apps were on our ad
network so he locked himself in his
bedroom it's like I'm gonna learn mobile
in the next six months and he just built
a bunch of Android games and then I saw
him on Twitter tweeting back with people
who played his game and I was like dude
none of my developers all the developers
I have in my company that are great none
of them would ever go tweet at a
customer and be like hey you know I'm
gonna fix that bug and I can make this
better
hey what do you think about this sounds
like there's something different about
this guy what apps were you shocked at
how big they were why their app does 200
oh the casino game I mean that's not
shocking is it um the size of it was
definitely shocking just because you all
assumed they're big and they're
addictive but then that and then candy
crush in their initial rise was the
first time in the industry where I heard
like man like dis ting is a money
printing machine it's like you know they
would you know and not all this was at
Apple eV and I said one turn at Tech
you're like learning about the industry
you're meeting other people when you're
like hey these guys are willing this
blanket pee but eight bucks for a user
in the US and I'm like okay well that
seems pretty expensive like why are they
doing that
like how much $8 what they're spending
yeah I think at that time it was like
hey if we're like a male you know 18 to
35 or something it might be eight bucks
or something like that and then on the
other side I talked to somebody over
there and I'm like they're like yeah
dude we make like 20 bucks on them like
in like seven days and I'm like and
maybe those numbers are slightly off but
like they were making a multiple to
where you were like wait so you just
have this machine where you just pressed
this button and you put in money and you
know seven days later three times more
money come out and I'm like wow like how
do I get that I don't my bank account
every single day to go do that well you
guys had that a little bit with that
beloved yeah I mean I didn't have that
right like I don't have the senior at
this company you're vested you have a
shared interest in the long run but you
know me being me I was like I want that
like I want the ability to have that and
then the freedom to work on things that
I'm really excited about and so I tried
that obviously it's a lot harder than
just you know one person in their
bedroom doing it but what did Adam Apple
of and say was he like this just we had
no idea or was he methodical and an item
is so fantastic at execution that is
just like he's like a machine it's like
you know when when the thing I really
loved about him and the things I learned
the most from him were like when you
wanted to go do something like you know
sometimes you're like oh man this
situation isn't working and Adams the
CEO of Apple of it yeah a CEO of Apple
oven and you know you have these
situations where it's like I gotta go do
the X or you really feel like you got to
go make this move this deals bad maybe
this hire was bad or this hire was good
or something like that
buddy what kind of weight on it a little
bit after deciding and you're gonna
create some time what's a good time to
do it for em like okay we'll just go do
this now like what's stopping us and
then you know the other things like that
were you know I started there as kind of
an engineer and then very quickly he was
like oh you could run this team you
could manage the whole team I was a
great we talked and then that kind of
always been my experience that like that
never really gets communicated and then
it feels like cool I'm like the manager
but not like I think a lot of people end
up in that situation especially in
companies and then like the next morning
it's like a meeting with the whole team
he puts that work chart up and then
every time we changed it it was the same
situation happened he was so clear and
effective with his communication and
execution that I was like like I really
need to be like that like that's what
like I think
Plus execution looks and feels like day
in and day out and it's like it's not
emotional it's very logical it's very
quick and I think speed in these
situations helps create clarity because
when you remember the other way around
clarity help create speed yeah we're
both right you know and I think clarity
in the system if you delay it your team
becomes unclear and then it gets a
little muddy and then you're like wait
what is what's going on here why is this
guy kind of acting like that and that
person not and I think just being very
fast and quick in that execution once
you decide you should go and execute it
and I think that that's that's the thing
that I learned is like how quickly can
you do that and how effectively can you
do that whether it's an email and I'm
really not good at this it's kind of one
of the reasons I point at it because I
see myself kind of like oh wait on this
a little bit or send this email tomorrow
I don't want to open up this kind of
world right now
like and then it's actually that's the
exact opposite traitor sake just go have
a bias for action and and kind of go do
that and so from him I learned just just
an amazing amount in like how do you
operate at this level and I mean since
I've left they've grown so much that it
feels like I was only at the 1% of it
like I feel like I don't know 90% 99% of
the story anymore because they've grown
well beyond that they've expanded into
other areas they're really big now from
the revenue side they're really big now
from you know what their marketplace is
and they're very well known and you know
I kind of get all the benefit from from
being there a long time ago which is
great for me but you know I'm sure there
were more learnings that I missed along
the way this whole monologue on app love
and that's gonna be our clip nice that
was a good one
cool we should wrap for today that was
awesome man for kind of works with me
across the street so anytime we want to
do this so we'll have people will put
your Twitter handle in the bio and the
notes of this and so people can get you
know follow you get you know tweet at
you whatever after this as well and we
don't know I'm still uncertain as to how
many listeners we have but I do know
that last time I asked for reviews we
got a few hundred of them and a handful
of hours to leave 24-48 hours so if you
like this one tweet at him you could say
your hand on a second and then let us
know and we'll we'll figure out what
what what next to do yeah yeah my handle
is a fur con or
on Twitter that's fu our qan are awesome
thank you